hello everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio at sundance's
2024 brought to you by filo a very cool
company that puts the power to greenl
movies in the hands of fans and creators
if you want to learn more about what
filo is doing check out their website
film. hello to the team from mugai
congratulations from short to feature
it's quite the accomplishment thank you
thank you for having us so a lot of
people out there are going to learn
about your movie through the Festival
I'll give this duty to one of you cuz
you both worked on the short who wants
to give everyone a brief description of
what the muga is about go for
m i you're
up uh so I think you should do like
every other
sentence word at a time sandwiches um um
so the mugy is a uh at the face of
it it's a um genre film a horror story
about a family who are going through a
an extremely traumatic experience post
the birth of their second child um the
mother Sarah starts to see things and
experience things that aren't
necessarily there for everyone else um
and that's kind of what it seems like
it's also an allegory for the stolen
Generations uh um policies in that that
uh dragged on through Australia's
history and is still dragging on today
um but yeah essentially my character um
is a kind of you know high functioning
very successful sees what she wants and
gets it kind of girl and uh for the
first time in her life she seems to be
losing a bit of her mind and uh a grip a
sense of reality but um no one else
quite believes her and um she just can't
cop a break really well I can't wait to
dig into those details but the first
thing I wanted to ask the two of you
because I get very obsessed with the
idea of people finding collaborators and
then having that longtime creative
partnership together and I know you had
that so can you recall the first time
you met and what you saw on the other
that signal to you like this is is
someone I want to work with forever yeah
uh it actually goes back to drama school
16 years ago 16 years ago we were at
Nida together and um um I'm really at
the at the core of it it was we were two
Aboriginal students in a in an Institute
of not a lot of Aboriginal students like
we were two out of four I think um and
so we bonded over that and um yeah we've
and then when I once I graduated we did
The Sapphires which was another film and
I think there was a couple of projects
that just happened to coincide that we
were in the same for I don't know a SP
like peripheral but we never sort of
talked to each other on screen or
anything this is this is actually the
first time that we've acted one-on-one
together in in any project I think so
that was exciting and you know we' been
dying to work with each other in that um
close proximity so knowing each other
but then working one-on-one together for
the first time here can you each
pinpoint something that the other did on
set that made you stop and say to
yourself like I knew you were good but I
didn't know you were capable of that oh
yeah I think there was a there's a scene
in the film where um uh between us two
and um we we're at the hospital and I I
think it's very high stakes high tension
and um you know um I'm there giving my
all and then sh is matching and going
above me so it was um it was good to be
able to play in that in that domain and
um be able to
with that such a high emotion and such
um and just being sitting in an awe of
shar's talent and being able to um have
to bring my aame to the to the plate so
I love that this is on video now
forever I'm not going to let this down
any not at
all um I think for me there was a I I
very rarely got to see the the split or
you know what the monitor at all but
there was a scene where I saw Maine in
the hospital as well in the psych ward
actually um and uh he's with our uh he's
the character is bringing the our eldest
daughter and there was just a really
kind of beautiful sense of um
vulnerability and Terror and strength
and you know all of those complex things
and it's like oh wow I I've seen him do
everything I've I've heard him talk for
so many years um we were housemates at
wees on stage we're best friends in real
life um but to actually yeah to kind of
have a moment to watch him and go oh far
out this this like that's my brother boy
and he's he's freaking awesome that's on
camera too film making families and
continued Partnerships just make me so
so happy I love hearing about them uh
broad question for you about horror
Bella because the last time you were
here of course was for Relic which is
streaming now on shutter so if you
haven't seen it what are you waiting for
what keeps you coming back to the genre
for more more but then can you pinpoint
something about the muuga that's
signaled to you this will add another
layer to genre
storytelling uh good question uh it's so
funny cuz obviously I seem to do a bit
of horror and I get asked about it a lot
and I love horror films when they're a
vehicle for something bigger like I mean
when I was a teenager I watch any
slasher film I was into all of them but
now like it has to be an allegory and
the thing I love about this is like it's
really dark subject matter and a dark
time in Australia's past present and um
but like the here comes the airplane of
the horror vehicle for that uh makes it
really entertaining and you know it's
funny I haven't seen the film and I
reread the script a couple of nights ago
just to remind myself you know ahead of
coming here and I was like man it's so
good it just like sucked me in and um
spat me out covered in tears so uh yeah
I I just think it's really important
story and I'm really excited I'm just
really proud to be involved actually one
of my favorite gen it is my favorite
genre and I just I love how you can use
genre story telling to dig into like
really difficult human truths and
sometimes it's an easier way to process
it I also just love having fun with the
horror genre so just for all three of
you what is the horror sub genre that
scares you most horror sub I I like a
psychological Thriller like that's
that's where the domain where you're not
it's not something that there's a force
in the in or something in the house kind
of thing it's there's more it's going up
between the ears and I think that sub
genre is really interesting to me solid
Choice yeah I like a supernatural
Thriller when it's you know the the
monster is kind of staved off screen for
as long as possible so you get that like
it's my imagination doing much more work
than um than audiences are used to so
our imagination is often way more
horrifying than what we see on screen
exactly right
yeah that's what I was going to
say no but it is because you know and
and the idea of the psychological horror
too and
just like all the things your brain will
do to fill the gaps that are often more
terrifying than than what's actually on
the screen just a selfish question
because again I love horror for each of
you if you had the opportunity to join
the iconic horror franchise of your
choice what franchise would you pick and
why I have many suggestions if you need
them n scream's fun scream's fun cuz
that's my number one scream Fran you can
you can pick scream if you want well I
think because that's our generation we
grew up with that that film coming out
at the time so that that was always a
fun one for me yeah I really like uh
Conjuring is one of my favorite films so
but I also like just how silly it's
gotten so I think in terms of a a fun
Journey it's like to start off with
something so kind of sophisticated and
then end up with Annabelle like C in I
mean can we also say it's maybe not
technically uh a series but the craft I
mean they made a second one oh they did
that film original craft that was iconic
when I was at school all excellent
choices right there I will also pitch
Final Destination oh yeah one my
favorite horror franchises that doesn't
get the credit of it's terrifying when
you go on the road and the there's like
wood on the back of a or you're in the
plane and it's like who everyone looking
around I always wonder if I if I booked
a flight and it was flight 180 would I
actually get on it I probably would um
back to your film now for the two of you
having worked on the short I'm curious
what is something about your version of
the character and the short that you
knew you wanted to hold tight to and
bring to the feature but then also what
is a new layer that you were especially
excited to add in the featurelength
version uh I think for me it was Sarah's
deep maternal um love unconditional deep
protective and fierce love for her
children and her family and what costs
what lengths she'll go to protect that
uh what was that's what I would that's
what I wanted to hold on to um what was
new to me me was actually um John then
sort of flipping that on it on it head
and a way and um maybe on the surface
she doesn't seem like the most maternal
person so it became a bit more
complicated in that sense um a mother
that isn't necessarily you know going to
like she wasn't overly coddling to her
children or anything like that so yeah I
thought it was fun an impossible
question to ask you about that I'll let
main answer first and then we'll Circle
back yeah I think I think in the short I
really wanted to hold on to the reality
and the stakes knowing that we're going
into a genre film and um you know we've
got a malevolent spirit in the film but
it's also making sure it's keeping
grounded I suppose cuz that's that's
your gateway into the genre I suppose
and then I think when it came to the
feature what I liked with the character
and the exploration um that I could go
further with was it turned out to be a
bit of a gaslighting bastard and that
was fun to play with you know like um
and I i' I relished in that opportunity
okay so two impossible questions first
one's for you Bella because no no small
roles in a movie and it really it it
blows my mind when someone's able to
take limited screen time to support the
main character's narrative but also make
sure that their character feels like
they're whole and they have history
what's the secret sauce how do you pull
that off uh great director and an acting
coach that's my secret Source I I just
have to do all the work beforehand I
think um cuz it's also the thing that I
find the most terrifying about that is
you're also coming on to the film like
typically once it's already started uh I
feel like the kind of new kid at school
and you're there for maybe a week or two
like it's it's a brief period and you
need to like fit into the world and I'm
I'm for some reason I don't know maybe
it's bizarre and backwards I feel much
more responsibility when I have a small
role in a film like oh God I don't want
to like these guys are great and I want
to be like the dud that stands out then
like and I and and I'm going to stop
talking about my insecurities
um we were like y y
say yeah a great director just to follow
up because I feel like we also don't
talk about acting coaches nearly enough
can you tell me something about your
acting coach that you really appreciate
and kind of Suits how you best like to
receive and apply notes um so I started
working her name's Warner Laughlin and I
had worked with many other people
previously and the thing that I love
about her because typically I will just
use substitution like my mom died when I
was young and I will just like flog that
dead horse on every film that I could
and you know I had a brother who died
half brother anyway so like I would just
use that again and again and it's
traumatizing and not good for your
psyche and also there's some days when
you get on set and your brain's just
like no I'm not going there I'm not
going into that and the thing about
Warner is that she has this way like of
creating a whole life and history for
that character and like sort of like
memories that what there's different
lingo that she uses but that that I can
then like put on like a coat and take
off and it feels just as authentic but
it like at the end of the day I'm not
shattered oh it's such an important
thing to be able to do all right I'm
going to end with my other impossible
question so you kind of brought this up
before a little bit what is the key to
playing your character with authority
but while knowing that in the end
product she needs to spark doubt in the
viewers yeah ah gosh which you do quite
well great we haven't seen it
so um do you know uh I think it was um
constantly checking in with John that
where we were pitching her you know as
as um people are
aware filming is all out of you know
sequence and you try and stay as close
to scene order as you can um but
checking with John every day uh and um
just actually having conversations all
the time about her internal life um and
what this sense like losing what losing
control feels like to her because she's
never experienced it before um and you
know it's I think a lot of women yet
it's kind of a scary thing because we
have such little of it to begin with in
society so when you fight so hard for it
um and then it's being dragged away from
you um it's it's quite scary so yeah
that's a great question thank you no no
easy answer to that like it feels like
like movie Magic that my brain can't
begin to process so a job very well done
in that respect huge congratulations on
the MU guy and thank you so much for
being here and sharing some of your
experience making the movie with us
thank you for having us so everyone out
there keep an eye out for the Mugi and
also all more interviews from Sundance
2024 and finally thank you to
filo